foreign
[Music]
ERS favors and his graciousness
now we ask him to raise the mission of
and Grant
Eternal peace to the messenger of Allah
foreign
[Music]
peace to his family and his companions
to begin
he said in his book
describing
all of the disbelievers
and all of them which we came
in
you know
[Music]
do you not see
all Muhammad
the one who has taken
his desires as his deity
the one who has taken his own desires
as his deity
[Music]
could you ever be a guardian for him
meaning against Allah
[Music]
likewise
Majestic is mentioned
he says in his book
all right
don't you see the one who has taken
who has taken his God as his desires
foreign
despite their having knowledge of the
truth despite having certainty
of
correct beliefs
and correct morals and so on and so
forth the person he followed his whims
and he followed his desires and he took
them as a god
besides Allah
[Music]
today inshaallah
in light of these two verses and a light
of his statement
attributed to some of the sahaba
what that Tanzania
foreign
[Music]
caterers
that the person who falls into illicit
sexual
relations and indecency and immorality
wishes that the rest of the woman and
the rest of the people would be like
them
and talk about
what is commonly referred to as the
court of the self
the court of the South
what is sometimes called the culture of
authenticity
and to trace
some of the history behind it that has
led us to the current moment
in the western world and in the world in
general
going back
for some time but specifically
from
around the time of the European
enlightenment
in the late 18th century
up until the current ERA
and when we arrive at the Karen area at
the current ERA we're going to talk
about what is called the therapeutic
culture
therapeutic departure we're going to
talk about the Contours of the modern
South
and
what
constitutes
selfhood and identity in the modern
world today
and what forms the basis of Education
and forms the basis of
inauthentic morality
and what form is the basis of governance
in the western world
that has become a replacement religion
and a place and a replacement God
and the world in which we live
one of the phrases
that is commonly used
in the current ERA is that a person
should live their truth
to live your truth
the truth to them is intuitional
it is something that comes from within
it is a gut feeling
how the person feels
and in what they feel comfortable with
any of their impulses and their urges
and their desires
is their personal truth
and this
matter and this false belief
is at the core and has been at the core
of Western thought
from its conception and from its
beginning
from the time of the
record Persian Awards hundreds of years
before
during the rise of Hellenism and the
rise of Greek philosophy
any
and it is a
critic and it is to bring multiple
cultures and multiple belief systems
together
into a hard page
mishmash
sludge
that is contradictory in nature
and
Western
fun
is premised upon you and as it relates
to his view of the truth
is premised upon a number of things this
is what will open up the talk with
inshallah
firstly
[Music]
the belief that there is an actual truth
that the truth exists the truth is out
there somewhere
and there is no viable culture there is
no person there is no way to have
identity
Muslim
for a certainty without the truth
and the truth is how in Islam
the truth is defined in the Arabic
language as what is real
and the witnessable world and the world
of the Unseen
and how one ought to be
what is real what is factual
and how one ought to be how one should
be
and he
and
true information
from reliable sources
there is no one more truthful than Allah
and then more truthful than the message
[Music]
and in the
trustworthy carriers of the religion
over the course of place and time
who came with
the teachings of the religion and the
explanation and that understanding and
proper interpretation of those teachings
as we lead to the rights of Allah and
the rights of people
what is
[Music]
and so
the opposite it's found in the western
world that they believe
and have always believed
in their various iterations and the
various versions of Western thought from
the beginning of the concept of there
being a place called The West
any up until today
that there is a truth that the truth is
out there somewhere however the truth is
something that no one can fully reach
it's something that no one can fully
reach they never had anything that was
authoritative enough to identify as
being the final truth
the final truth
and so
the truth exists they say
and they purport it for the time of the
Greek philosophers and all throughout
and word and indeed the truth exists
however there is no absolute or final
Authority there is no absolute or final
Authority because no one has the full
picture of the truth
because no one has a full picture of the
truth but rather every person of good
will every person who feels warm and
fuzzy inside and who claims to have a
good intention
they say
and they claim
that every person of Goodwill has their
own version of the truth
and their own perspective that is based
upon their intuition and based upon
their personal life experiences
and they say that
through discussion and debate and
disputing
about what one has learned or one has
uh experienced
that these different viewpoints and
these aspects of the truth can be pulled
together
they can be pulled together to form a
temporary consensus
a temporary consensus that is an
approximation of the truth that is close
to the truth and closer to the truth and
individual sources
however it is just a temporary
approximation
temporary in this nature and it can
change very quickly as people go through
new experiences and as people receive
additional information they reformulate
what is the truth with them
and so the truth with them
is always a process of becoming
any that people are in a process of
becoming a western Societies in a
process of becoming as best self
and people get successively closer to
the truth
slowly but surely they claim without
ever fully reaching it
and so this mysterious process of
becoming
went through many different versions and
we're going to jump forward in history
past
the
paganization of Christianity
when the teachings of racism
were given a Western interpretation of
philosophical metaphysical
interpretation
by the early church fathers
and then after that
with these schisms in the church and
then after that with what is called the
germanization of Christianity where the
people of Western Europe
the Germanic tribes accepted
Christianity and Blended their Pagan
beliefs and their Pagan celebrations
with
Catholicism
and
the court of the Saints and took the
celebrations that they were upon and the
beliefs that they were upon and merged
them with Christianity
and remained like that for a long period
of time as we jump forward in history to
the 16th century with the rise of
protestantism
and the Advent of
Martin Luther
then Christianity
split
between
Catholicism and protestantism and
protestantism was based upon just that
protesting the teachings of
the Catholic church and the corruption
of the Catholic church and the worship
of the Saints on all these sorts of
things and they introduced the concept
and gave Focus to a concept
of what they call the agency of the Holy
Spirit
in a way that had not been formulated in
the same way before
they said that
every person who is
upon Christianity every person was a
true Christian they have the ability to
interpret scripture for themselves to
read the Bible they said
for themselves and to interpret it for
themselves
and so this caused Christianity to
schism
protestantism is schism
and to many different directions or many
different sects
and
what had existed
and have been under the radar to a great
deal
I needed to a great degree a great deal
any of the Aquatic beliefs any of the
practice of Witchcraft and magic and the
cultism and so on and so forth started
to resurface all throughout
the Western Christian world
[Music]
and we find ourselves
uh a turning point
in Christianity and a turning point and
Western thought
and he will be
the Advent of the Enlightenment over the
time of the Enlightenment and the 18th
century
in the 18th century
where you had a number of thinkers who
said that
private advice
that private advice and private Behavior
and he even if it is sinful
and even if it is built upon greed
and that which is not of a benefit any
of that
it has the potential for or it gives
rise to
public virtue and it's a public virtue
it is for the greater good
that people pursue their self-interest
it is for the greater good that people
pursue their desires and that what
occurs within the confines of one's home
and one's private life is Nobody's
Business
if that is nobody's business and that
in fact
[Music]
the economy of the world
will benefit greatly
from people being however they want to
be in private
and that this became the concept of
authenticity
this was something that was promoted by
a number of Enlightenment thinkers like
John Jack Russell and life
Renee the car and others from the
alignment thinkers
and he who said
that
firstly
selfhood and identity and what makes a
person who they are
as opposed to the Islamic
[Music]
concept and the Islamic
outline and framework
that
what makes a person virtuous and what
makes a person live a good life is
righteousness and obedience to Allah
and enjoying and being grateful for what
our lives permitted of the things of
this world and building a family and
working for the Hereafter and fulfilling
one Society to role
that they flipped the script on that
and they said that what brings a person
happiness is two things firstly
authentic selfhood is that a person
turns inwardly they look inwardly and
that their passions and their desires
and their wants and their urges is who
they authentically are
and who they who they authentically are
and that they are naturally good that
they are naturally good and what they
want is naturally good
and secondly about what keeps people
from being their authentic selves
is Society at Large
and
the role of religion and society and the
role of governance in society
and that
Society itself
victimizes people
and the traditional mores of society
repressed people and keep them from
being their authentic selves
so the claimers
that the modern self
is realized that a person becomes their
authentic self that authenticity is
achieved by a person acting hourly and
according to one's inward feelings and
that a person that theirself
is divine
who is part Divine that they are solve
their soul is divine and that the world
and Society is a prison keeping them
from authenticity and keeping them from
true happiness
so
an Inward and downward reorientation
occurs
and as opposed to what was traditionally
held by societies
Muslim are not Muslim
that
happiness in life
and purpose in life
and heroism
and bravery
and Valor
comes by a person working for the
hereafter
working for the next life
holding on to their religious morals and
fulfilling their societal world
as comes in its correct form
and the statement of the Prophet was
[Music]
that the messenger of Allah
he was asked about the thing that enters
people into Hellfire the most
and he said
[Music]
he said they are
any two parts of the body the mouth and
the private parts
the mouth and the private parts what a
person says with their tongue and what
they ingest and to their stomach
and what they do with their private
parts and their person's appetites
any for food and food
sexual intercourse
and he is and the way that they speak
and what they use their tongue for is
the most likely thing to enter a person
into the Hellfire these people they say
that happiness comes in a person hourly
expressing with this tongue and
advocating
and he had at the head of that
is illicit sexual relations outside of
marriages will come to see
which would eventually become the
linchpin and the core of what identified
people
historically
and the prophesan was then asked
[Music]
what is the thing that will enter people
into Paradise the most
foreign
[Music]
punishment in the hereafter
a good character in dealing with others
likewise the problem is
[Music]
after mentioning how Satan will come
Europe
and he an increasing severity
every time trials and temptations come
they will make the previous and prior
trials and tribulations seem
insignificant in comparison
is
and whoever would like to be distanced
far away from the health and entered
into Paradise then let him reach his
Mania his death
his demise
what he believes in Allah in the
way that he would like to be dealt with
and treated himself
let him treat within let him treat and
deal with people
the way that he would like to be treated
and the way that he would like to be
dealt with
and so
the orientation
became turned upside down
and with that came a loss of meaning
came a loss of meaning and the
purpose of life became in the Western
World increasingly
and the purpose of the institutions of
society from education up to governance
increasingly became instead of looking
towards the Hereafter to look down
towards this world
and to make the primary focus this world
prophesy saw Refuge with Allah
prophesied some of his companions they
were
intelligent and they were the wises of
people when it came to governance and
when it came to political matters and
when it came to
any uh
trade and business and so on and so
forth and they did that and they were
able to do that by making the hair after
their priority
as comes in the statement of the
messenger of Allah
was the messenger of Allah
[Music]
and whoever makes it Hereafter his main
concern
and Allah will organize his worldly
matters for him
and he will place richness in that
person's heart
[Music]
and the Dunya will be cut and the Dunya
will be forced to come to that person
and the Dunya this world will be forced
to come to that person
and whoever makes us
whoever makes this world their main
concern and their main ambition
and Allah will scattered and
disorganized his worldly matters
wow
[Music]
and he will place poverty
between that person's eyes all he will
see is poverty
is
up for what Allah had already written
for him meaning that his sustenance will
not be blessed
and his efforts will be in vain on the
day that he meets Allah
and in the blessings of Allah
upon him in a worldly sense will be and
he will be a source of
Destruction for him in the hereafter
and so the orientation
became
completely different
from looking upward
towards
the meeting with the Creator and
preparing for the hereafter
and he too looking downward towards this
world
and the prophet saw Allah
and was a prophesy on the lengthy do I
have part of which is the prophesy is
allow this world to be our highest
concern or our
do not allow this world to be the extent
of our knowledge or our greatest concern
the extent of our knowledge
or our greatest concern
and so
in a word
with this selfie
is and with this
authentic identity as they claim it is
what it is is individualism
individualism any that people they
believe that as individuals focusing
upon one's personal concerns are making
that their priority that they live their
most authentic lives and that a person
has naturally lived until they have
checked off everything off their bucket
list any of their personal whims and
their personal desires
and so on and so forth and one of the
most disturbing
aspects of this
with this loss of meaning
and with this loss of what
gives a person Valor a virtue in life
and he is the abolition of Shame
the abolition of Shame
by way of the normalization
and the celebration
and the vulnerization of sexual
indecency and devency such as
homosexuality and today transgenderism
and pornography and promiscuity
and this began
at least 200 years ago in the western
world
at an increased and it's time for an
increase in the severity to a point that
is beyond what anybody could have
imagined even 20 years ago or 30 years
ago
[Music]
how polar famously said
um
that nations are only determined by
their morals and their ethics
nations are only determined by
their morals and their ethics and their
virtues
in so long as those ethics and those
morals and those virtues survive and
remain
[Music]
they will remain they will survive so
long as their morals and their values
and their virtues to
survived
and once they will depart this is the
reason for the decline and the fall of
Nations
and so
The Contours
and the descriptions of the Western
South are focused around this matter of
individualism
that we describe
any of a person
determining who they are going to be
outwardly by their inward passions and
their inward desires without it
without any
[Music]
things to judge by of traditional
morality or revealed religion or
anything of the sort
it is instantaneous gratification it is
a
immediate and he limited Outlook at life
that causes
and if that causes the fragmentation of
society and fragmentation
of the family
secondly
after individualism is the means to
achieve
personal growth as they say
and inexorable progress as they claim
any social progress and individual
progress any which is to give the
greatest focus in education to material
knowledge
and
scientific knowledge
and technological advancement
there is no doubt
that individualism by itself that a
person is not swayed by the majority and
that they think for themselves
in the
in light of the truth and in light of
their actual fiction that is something
that is praised with
there is some there is much Merit to it
any but without that without divine
revelation without guidance
for a person to identify right from
wrong and where the individual self is
assigned the status of divinity
and made an actual God
and the minds and the hearts of people
and there is no doubt that that is the
most destructive matter and there is no
doubt that saying that science and
scientific investment and technology is
of great importance in the world today
and in every time in every place has
been of great importance to people and
is necessary for Safety and Security and
prosperity and so on and so forth but
when that becomes the most important
thing to learn about and when moral
education and religious education is
said to be a matter of Aesthetics a
matter of taste
that doesn't
measure up to the scientific method they
say
and you have what is called scientism
the abuse of Science and the misuse of
Science and the misuse of Technology
and the application of Science and
scientific method to things that it is
inapplicable to
from human behavior and from the realm
of politics and diplomacy and ethics and
morality and so on and so forth
and so what comes as a result of the
combination of these two things
when the entirety of the focus or the
greatest Focus that is given by Society
at large and the individuals
that comprise the society and the
identity of those people collectively
and he is the focus on the self and the
desires of the self and that everybody
lives their own truth and is entitled to
their own opinion about every single
matter
and that what is most important is
personal advancement
and one's own pocket
and the way to get that which is
scientific knowledge and technological
progress and so on and so forth that
what comes as a result of that is
a loss of Natural Freedom
as it was stated by any man say with
Islam
and I have been blessed to have gathered
a good amount of that nation in the
publication winning the war Within
[Music]
the loving
worship of Allah
that they have been created for the
servitude that they have been created
for
eign
and as a result of that they were
afflicted by becoming the slaves of
their own selves and the slaves of the
shaytan
by slavery to the slavery to the shaytan
so much has been written in the history
of Islam have added enough's discipline
in the soul imparting virtuous character
to the soul and
struggling against the soul struggling
against the inner self
and the harmful impulses and passions of
the inner self and he to the point that
this is the core of Islam Allah sent
guidance to the
prophetam to remove people from
the passions and the desires of their
souls to being the loving worshipers of
Allah
and then this is
Eternal happiness for a person in this
world and the next any person who
attempts
to try
the Islamic method with genuineness and
sincerity they will find us to be the
case
they will find that the more they know
of the religion and the more that
affects their ambition and the more that
affects their intention and the more
that affects their character and the
more that affects their behavior and
fulfilling Allah's rights and the rights
of other people including the rights of
their own self
the happier they will be the more
dignified they will be the more
prosperous they will be as individuals
and families and as communities and
entire societies and Nations
and then whenever this is lost whenever
this formula of beneficial religious
knowledge coupled with sincere intention
and high ambition
coupled with
High lofty morality identified conduct
that when that is lost
and that is the cause of the decline of
Nations and the colossian societies
so what comes as a result of the
combination of the turn inward and
downward
and you're making
one's entire purpose of life and what
gives a person meaning and what makes
you you or makes a person
what makes a person's identity and what
makes a person having
an authent to have an authentic life and
it becomes a turned downward and inward
where a person looks at their personal
whims without any
consideration of the actual truth and
they say that their emotions and their
feelings are Divine in origin
our divine in origin and that they are
the truth that their intuitions and
their gut feeling that that is the truth
and that their personal advancement and
their
personal prosperity and wealth it
becomes a culture of adolescence the
culture of juvenile
that doesn't have any grit or any
resilience or the coping mechanisms that
are necessary to survive
the trials of life
and the entirety of the Focus Education
and governance of someone who becomes
the advancement of
technology and scientific discovery and
so on and so forth
then you have
what is called a bureaucratic culture
an agricultural bureaucracy educational
bureaucracies and
corporate democracies and
governmental bureaucracies whose purpose
is to guarantee
the living standards of people
not what is a regreted good for them
actually not what is better for them
ethically and more on
any but what will make them happy and
what will keep them placated will keep
them
docile
and this is what has been referred to by
many Western writers as soft despotism
a soft despotism and it is
uh
the manipulation of society by way of
corruption is to rule people by
corruption and keep them weak and keep
them down trying to keep them ignorant
and keep them dociled
by way of the valorization of corruption
and immorality and so on and so forth
I saw a number of phases
were passed through to get to the point
that we are at today
we mentioned the first things
and we mentioned the first phase in the
modern era which was the time of the
Enlightenment or some of the
Enlightenment thinkers
and the rise
of the concept
that political and social change
drastic
socio-political change is very possible
and that the authority to carry out
their changes in the hands of
individuals
so it became
what somehow caught a fire in the minds
of men the Revolutionary Faith a faith
of rebellion a replacement of religion
that was
promoted and that came to
a boiling point during the French
Revolution at the end of the 18th
century with the models of
what is Liberty
[Music]
and equality
and these three models
these three slogans of the French
Revolution and the reign of terror
with all the Guillotines and heads
rolling and so on and so forth
and in all the blood that was said at
that time
materialized
and they were the slogans first and
foremost of Freemasonry
I mean material lines into three
different political systems
that would wage war against each other
at the turn of the 20th century for the
almost the first half the 20th century
and they were capitalism because Liberty
and freedom and economic freedom and in
free trade
[Music]
fraternity and Brotherhood meaning
nationalism
which was fascism and social democracy
which was Nazism
and equality
which was communism and socialism
men
each other these ideologies they met
each other in the battlefield
for much of the first half of the 20th
century and caused Bloodshed and
Devastation beyond what the world has
ever seen before or since
so this
is enough for us in reality
it's even enough for us in reality to
see the reality
of
the end game and the enemies
are one following their desires and the
believer doesn't have to learn the hard
way
and the believer he knows that it is if
his own self
if it is left untamed and unchecked is
the worst enemy that he has that gives
authority to the shaytan over him and
that forsakes him and leaves him in a
pitiful condition then what about the
nuts of another person what about the
unfolds of other people what about other
people's souls and souls and their
personal objectives and their personal
goals and what they are after
and so a number of movements throughout
the long 19th century
came into prominence
that DFI
the self of the person
that deified the self of the person
and the after methane and you have the
what is called the American creed
of life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness that the pursuit of happiness
that became a human right
it became a human right not inclusive
for everybody but inclusive to certain
demographics of people that were the
ruling classes and that were the uh
ethnic majority and the end
the United States and elsewhere and the
anglo-american world and the
euro-american world and that sort of
thing
and
you had a movement in the first half of
the 19th century I mean between around
1800 and 1840 that was called
romanticism
when you hear the word Romanticism what
comes to mind
what comes to mind when you hear the
word romantic
what comes to mind
[Music]
what what does it mean
a person is romantic and so that guy's a
romantic over there what does that mean
it's French
what does it mean though
that means like love passion like like
marital love or like relationship like
relational love that sort of thing so
the romanticists they
taught that nature was divine and they
looked at the developments of urban
society and they had Nostalgia for the
past and they tried to look into the
Pagan past for the source of Happiness
before Christianity and they said they
didn't believe in any given religion and
they were a number of poets and
playwrights and even painters and
artists and so on and so forth and
musical composers and they had a
movement for the first half of the 18th
century from 1800 or so to 1840 and he
where they placed Divinity in nature and
within nature
and he they said it was part part of
nature was man and he returned Back To
Nature returned Back To Nature as a
source of happiness and he leaving the
urban centers and the squad of the urban
centers and so on and so forth returned
Back To Nature and with that
they purported that and they claimed
that one of the greatest source of
authenticity and happiness for this self
is romantic love and this became
something that was why he studied and
widely memorized
by the upper echelons of society and by
those who were about to do as well by
some of the poor classes who were
littering and it became the digest of
the people any media that they consumed
for the first half of the 18th century
and the second half of the 18th century
you had a movement in America that was
called transcendentalism
and you wear it they say that mankind
has transcended societal norms and
societal uh expectations and so on and
so forth you know and a number of people
like uh Thoreau and others any who along
with this return back to Nature
that they said explicitly that the self
is designed that the self is divine that
the inner self of the person that is
divine and that
happiness resides in the prison living
their most authentic life living their
most authentic life
and at the same time in Europe you had
the rise of occultism you had the rise
of theosophy you have the rise of uh
what will become in the 1950s and 60s
New Age spirituality Eastern religions
being discovered any in the colonies and
the lands in the East especially that
have been colonized by the European
powers that they exported translations
of the Hindu text and of taoism and
confucism and every other type of ism
and you're from Eastern spirituality
back home back to the West the people
they wanted something exotic and they
wanted something different that wasn't
Christianity
and they wanted to have some identity
that was different than everything in
the past
and during the second half likewise of
the 19th century Annie meaning the 1800s
you had
the writings of Charles Darwin the
Origin of Species and the survival of
the fittest and these sorts of Concepts
that
claim that human beings were just
intelligent animals that they were just
intelligent animals which reinforced
this long-standing belief and claimed
that authentic self put and true
identity and he is by a person looking
inward at their gut feeling and how they
personally feel and what they personally
want and that sort of thing
I mean along with that you hide
the writings of Sigmund Freud
and he who was a cokehead
and there is much that has been written
there is an entire book actually that
was written about how Freud's best
uh
Epiphany moments in his mind where he
came up with many of his theories as
sexualized identity
that place what a person is and who a
person is not just in their desires and
their inner feelings but their sexual
feelings and their sexual urges that he
came to these conclusions while coked
out in his mind
he arrived at these conclusions where
I'm coked out of his mind snorting
cocaine and any uh abusing opium and so
on and so forth
and so you have this perverted person
Sigmund Freud who sexualized identity
and who came up and who was a Pioneer in
the field of psychoanalysis that were
turned into I mean uh psychology and
social psychology and other things and
who sexualized identity
then at the same time you had a teaching
lab
Karl Marx
which politicized identity and pitted
mankind as the victors and the victims
the victors and the victims and it is
time for the poor and the down trial and
the victims to overthrow their
overseeders and their Imperial Lords and
so on and so forth and to rise up and to
revoke I need to give authority to the
masses
and so the teachings of Marxism
taught that people are either victims or
victors
and it
placed Identity or focus and identity
and victimhood
a victimhood
and likewise at the same time around
that same period of time in the latter
half of the 19th century you had uh
what is
[Music]
which are the teachings of the likes of
Nisha and others and he who
said that men are Divine human beings
are Divine who Acclaim the death of God
who claim that the belief in God has
died and claimed that he what is called
uh the the disenchantment of the world
and either the world has lost any type
of Enchantment any belief in the Unseen
the sonar of the door and that who you
are is how you feel who you are is how
you feel and that human beings have the
potential if they were to tap into their
willpower
if they were to tap into their willpower
and Trust in themselves
and to have confidence in themselves to
become gods and to evolve into God
and this is the sludge
and the filth that became globalized
throughout the second half of the
19th century that led as can be proved
empirically and has been written about
exhaustively by Western
academics and historians themselves that
led to the atrocities and the Bloodshed
of the first half of the 20th century of
the first half of the 20th century with
the world wars with the Cold War and the
spread of Communism and so on and so
forth
after the world wars
we have what was called the rise of the
therapist War prism is an extension of
the therapy
was the popularization taking
away all of the
Babel and all of the uh clear
uh foolishness of the new age beliefs of
Eastern spirituality so on and so forth
that claim
that gave people uh
a boost and self-esteem by claiming that
they were divine and that their souls
were divine and that
authenticity resided within a person
tapping into their inner potential
without any other consideration
any these sorts of beliefs any that
people are one with the divide and that
the self if left to his desires are left
to its whims and left to achieve what it
says how to achieve
that it will become one with nature and
that nature is God
and that
this is I mean this is without a doubt
pantheism and this is a belief in and
in the Oneness of existence that a
person becomes one with the universe
and you have all of these sorts of
belief systems connected to uh connected
to Chi and connected to uh other forms
of
Eastern spirituality any that a person
is one with the universe and use the
force and all these sorts of things that
I found in popular literature and
popular uh media and movies and so on
and so forth
and so the therapeutic culture was a way
to give a scientific
or a scientistic a pseudoscientific
[Music]
interpretation to the new age
to the new age
and the end it consists of a number of
things and we'll close on these points
the first
and he is a cultural widespread
preoccupation with the individual itself
to replace religion and traditional
morality
and he with the individual self and the
desires of the self as a diamond way of
viewing the world
and your purpose and your meaning in
life secondly
and a notable concern with the place of
emotions and making sense of who you are
and your place in the world and this is
what we already heard this was something
that had been building up for
Generations
by that point
thirdly
and this is what made
the period after the world war is
different up until today with the
Counter Culture and the therapeutic
caution I need the emergence of the new
class of counselors and psychologists
and therapists that are socially
recognized and accredited as the experts
in their field as the most Quantified
to educate the children as the most
qualified to guide
the self and its emotions and the
complexities of the emotions
throughout the chaos of modern social
life
next
the reinterpretation of many behaviors
and he has been
things that were incurable things that
are any labeled as addictions and
disorders and dysfunctions any things
that
people have always dealt with generally
of unhealthy impulses unhealthy urges of
depression and sorrow and sadness that
comes naturally in life and anxieties
that come naturally in life saying that
the only way to navigate through one's
feelings is to go
to a specialist and to go to an expert
and that parents are not equipped to do
that for their children
and that
clergy and religious leaders are not
equipped to do that for their
communities
and that
in order for government policy to be
based upon
or to be effective and to be uh
something that is quote unquote
Progressive that it must be based upon
some pseudoscientific theories connected
to all of this cycle about them
lastly and this segues into tomorrow's
topic is
it became widespread caution became
culturally widespread and accepted I
need to use the language of victimhood
and he that
a person is victim of circumstance any
any woman are the victims of men things
like the patriarchy any anybody who
stops you or disagrees with you or does
not celebrate or valorize or applaud you
for your sexual proclivities
that that person has victimized you that
person has victimized you that anybody
who is in between you or anything or any
Creed that is in between you and your
authentic self has victimized you and
has oppressed you
and has oppressed you and so a cultural
victimhood anywhere every trifling
inconvenience in the life of a person is
labeled to be trauma and people are
looked at to be frail and fragile and
vulnerable creatures that cannot survive
without the guidance of counselors and
therapists and so on and so forth and
this became commonplace
became commonplace
so this is where we conclude this
evening
and tomorrow shall our time and we build
on some of what we heard today to speak
about wokeism
and the reality of wokism and waking up
to this
bitter ideology I need the cynical
ideology I need that has the World by
its clutches in a time in which we live
everything any
is another person or victimized another
person
all of these sources of of absurdities
we ask a lot it's about to protect us
and our children and our communities
from the influx of these poisonous
doctrines
[Music]